ma fait que des sûr il faut que je
t'emmène quelque part je pense que c'est
là un nazi alors ça c'est une reprise de
la production
c'est une surprise curry de toi
également non d'accord ou essaient de la
production il quand on combat ce pas là
je sais pas si folle d'amour qui fête
ses 25 ans
et 25 ans ça se fête et essayent tout et
qui fait peur je crois que tu les
connais pas le shérif comment ça va
empêcher les coutumes merci d'être là
les amours alors c'est ça alors c'est
que des jeunes de tous voilà qui nous
qui me regardent depuis des années
c'était facile et chérie et ses
magnifiques cette petite scène et tout
j'adore
alors ils m'ont prépare une petite
surprise et on prépare une petite
surprise une petite chanson pour ce
après fois que j'ai lancé une chorale
mois alors général c'est là on va faire
une chorale beau frère s'il est là les
chats je vous laisse avec avec le m
merci mon anniversaire syrie chéri merci
à mr ya une chanson
[Musique]
palafox ya des
sourit la mairie
je suis depuis quand on est très jeune
fille
il s'agit
à toi
oh
c'est
justin
chaud
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tiens
après que vous
[Applaudissements]